questa corda mi ha salvato la vita
ero a circa 6.000 metri sul nanga parbat
a questa montagna altissima di 8.125
metri che si trova in pakistan stava
scalando quando in pieno inverno a
quelle altitudine un ancoraggio ha
ceduto e sono caduto nel vuoto
vedete oggi sono qui a raccontarvi
questa storia proprio perché una corda
molto simile a questa ha tenuto il mio
volo e quindi posso raccontarvi la mia
storia su questa montagna incredibile
dove sono stato per ben 4 anni ero sulla
via chi soffre in questo versante
gigantesco della montagna in inverno a
30 40 50 gradi sotto zero ma il mio
sogno in realtà non era salire la via
che in sofferma riuscire a risalire al
centro di questa montagna all'inviolato
sperone mummery uno sperone fatto di
pareti rocciose di pareti di ghiaccio
una via elegante diretta e stupefacente
che sale quasi come una spada in vetta
al nanga parbat vedete affrontare uno
sperone inviolato vuol dire non soltanto
essere preparati tecnicamente e
fisicamente ma vuol dire anche avere il
coraggio di affrontare l'ignoto cioè ciò
che non si conosce
su montagne di questo tipo affrontare
l'ignoto vuol dire proprio avere il
coraggio di sopportare quella pressione
che ti fanno i luoghi che non sono mai
stati calpestati
questa zona della montagna è stata la
meta di un grandissimo sognatore albert
frederick maneri immaginate nel 1895
quest'uomo 60 anni prima che una
montagna di 8.000 metri forse scalata
parte dall'europa e al coraggio di
affrontare mesi di viaggio per arrivare
in pakistan e poi ai piedi di questa
montagna e per primo individua questo
sperone che dalla vetta scende fino alla
base della montagna
mummery e fu un uomo così coraggioso per
il quale questo tentativo che lui fece
di arrivare alla montagna passò alla
storia fu riconosciuto come il primo che
ebbe il coraggio di affrontare queste
montagne con mezzi leali con le proprie
forze le forze dei suoi compagni senza
mezzi artificiali senza corde fisse
senza portatori senza ossigeno e da quel
momento fu individuato come colui che
mise le basi proprio dello stile alpino
questo stile che prevede la scalata di
queste montagne in velocità e con poca
attrezzatura uno stile molto puro di
scalare le montagne vedete a un certo
punto mi sono ritrovato a 5.700 metri ho
scalato questo sperone ben due volte una
volta in compagnia e una volta in
solitaria quella volta ero da solo
ero nella tenda è affascinato da questa
storia incredibile di alba per federer
che mammarie con un certo punto ho
percepito come se fosse vero fuori dalla
tenda con lo sperone sopra di me con le
mie paure ero lì da solo è come se
avessi percepito realmente la presenza
di quest'uomo che faceva a scricchiolare
la neve è quasi mi accompagnava nel
desiderio di ripercorrere le sue orme ma
continuare ed andare su ho scalato lo
sperone però non sono riuscito ad
arrivare su quel prato finale per poi
arrivare in vetta ma veramente qui c'è
il vero motivo di essere andato in
inverno al nanga parbat e il fatto di
poter onorare quella figura audace di
albert herring mameli o usare lo stile
alpino in inverno su una via nuova per
cercare di fare anche da solo ciò che
non era mai stato fatto nella storia
dell'alpinismo
a quel punto però sceso dallo sperone
una sfida incredibile difficilissima
decido di cambiare rotta e di tornare
sulla via che sto per la via che so fare
una via percorsa d'estate più di 300
volte da tanti alpinisti da di tutto il
mondo tra cui anche la mia scalata che
avvenne nel 2008 ma in piena estate
nessuno è mai riuscito a scalare o
sprone mummery in inverno né tantomeno
in estate
ma la via che il sovra invece una via
che è stata percorsa tante volte ed è il
motivo per cui ci sono alcune
agevolazioni e facilitazioni sulla
montagna perché gli alpinisti a forza di
salire e scendere dalla montagna
lasciano degli ancoraggi sulla parete ed
alcune corde tra le quali anche quella
che come vi dicevo all'inizio di questo
racconto ha ceduto e mi ha lasciato
cadere nel vuoto
vedete al primo tentativo
sulla via che sofer in realtà arrivo
molto vicino alla vetta della montagna
circa 7.800 metri solo 300 metri dalla
vetta
a quel punto però uno dei miei due
compagni ha degli evidenti sintomi di
male a dell'acuto del male appunto di
montagna un male che nell'arco di pochi
minuti ti fa morire e in quel momento
senza nessun dubbio abbiamo deciso di
scendere dalla montagna quindi andare
verso il campo base e fermarci e li
vedete in quel momento ho capito una
cosa molto importante abbiamo provato a
fare questo volo verso la vetta della
montagna ma a volte succede che la brama
di arrivare in vetta oppure il desiderio
di salire sempre più in alto può essere
così incantatore che può farci
dimenticare quali sono i veri valori
della vita la vita stessa
sapete io scalo da una vita sin da
quando ero bambino e vivo a latina in
pianura pontina e potete immaginare che
le montagne lì proprio non sono il
paesaggio naturale pensate che quando ho
detto a degli amici che avrei voluto
scalare a 8.000 metri si sono messi a
sorridere eppure partendo dai miei monti
di 1500 metri poi ho avuto la forza e il
coraggio di salire in dolomiti sulle
alpi e poi ancora affrontare le montagne
di 8.000 metri e della terra quelle più
alte più affascinanti eppure in questo
percorso ho fatto tanti voli non solo
quelli sul nanga parbat e mi sono
accorto che a volte i voli non sono solo
il fatto di cadere dalla montagna avere
un pezzo di corda che trattiene il tuo
volo ma può vuol dire anche avere il
coraggio di affrontare le sfide di fare
un passo in là dove magari c'è quella
linea di ignoto dove possiamo andare a
conoscere qualcosa di diverso e
ritornando sempre a questa corda c'è
stato un momento proprio nell'inverno
scorso quando c'è stato anche il primo
volo in realtà ero lì sulla montagna a
scalare a cercare di fissare queste
corde non in stile alpino ma con uno
stile classico con un alpinista
incredibile un polacco adam bielecki a
un certo punto anche lui mentre fissa un
ancoraggio sulla parete scivola e cade
verso il basso metro dopo metro per 80
metri ero lì sulla parete con un solo
ancoraggio fra me e lui
potevo scegliere per una questione
nazionale o di sopravvivenza di
sganciare la corda dal mio imbrago e
lasciarlo cadere giù verso il basso
oppure magari bloccare della sua corda
su quell'ancoraggio lì perché a volte e
gli alpinisti fanno un tacito accordo è
quasi preferibile che va da via uno solo
piuttosto che entrambi ma io e adam non
eravamo così non siamo così abbiamo
scelto di fare una scalata insieme di
legare quel nodo e di salire insieme
ottenuto l'ancoraggio lui ha dato un
urto molto violento sulla mia corda ma
il mio peso ammortizzato questo e
sbattendo sulla parete l'ancoraggio ha
tenuto e noi siamo sopravvissuti lui
oggi ed ai suoi figli e io sono potuto
tornare a casa
ho imparato veramente tanto dalla
montagna ma dopo tutti questi incidenti
e scelte che possono far differenza se
tenere una corda
oppure lasciare e andar via alle prime
difficoltà oa qualsiasi difficoltà che
si incontra mi son chiesto in profondità
che senso avesse per me continuare a
scalare le montagne e andare sempre più
in alto ad affrontare tutte le
difficoltà che ci sono in fondo
all'epoca di mummery nel 1895 quando lui
tra l'altro non fece ritorno dalla
spedizione
l'obiettivo primario dell'alpinismo era
semplicemente vedere se l'uomo fosse in
grado veramente di arrivare sulle alte
vette una volta che queste erano state
salite e quindi che l'uomo era
dimostrato che poteva andare lì su in
realtà l'alpinismo si è spostato su un
altro campo cioè sulla qualità della
salita la capacità di utilizzare uno
stile veloce su pareti sempre più
difficili ma adesso cosa
qual è il significato a questo punto di
affrontare queste
lontani e soprattutto quando su in alta
quota si è come dentro un congelatore il
vento ci scherza e siamo lontani dalle
comodità che abbiamo giornalmente a casa
e soprattutto quando scaliamo in alta
quota sappiamo per certo che quando
superiamo i 7000 8000 metri
in realtà cominciamo a morire un po alla
volta e se io prendessi uno di voi e lo
portasse veramente in uno schioccar di
dita a 8.000 metri morirebbe di asfissia
nell'arco di pochi minuti noi alpinisti
possiamo essere qui perché saliamo
scendiamo dalla montagna più volte
proprio per far sì che il nostro corpo
si adatti all'alta quota e quindi dei
globuli rossi aumentino e possiamo fare
questa attività sportiva però capite
bene che siamo molto lontani dalla
situazione normale di agiatezza che
possiamo avere nella società
io credo che l'alpinismo
sia un mezzo incredibile lontano dai
condizionamenti sociali e civili di
affrontare un argomento che ha sempre
molto ostico cioè quello di in qualche
modo di scendere dentro noi stessi e
dentro la natura dell'uomo e cercare di
capire se effettivamente siamo fatti
solo di carne e ossa neuroni e molecole
oppure se dentro di noi c'è una forza
vitale o se siamo fatti di una forza
vitale che ci permette di decidere a
volte se rimanere in cordata con i
nostri amici se continuare a sfidare la
vita a perseverare oppure se abbandonare
a qualsiasi difficoltà
a quel punto credo che c'è una magia
nella scalata vedete su questo capo di
corda a un lato di questo capo ci sono
legato io potrebbe esserci è legato uno
di voi però non è finita qui all'altro
capo c'è una donna o un uomo che hanno
deciso di legarsi alla vostra corda
vedete ogni volta che si vola questa
corda potrebbe fare ben poco se non ci
fosse all'altro capo qualcuno che abbia
deciso di tenere quella corda e quindi
trattenere il vostro volo e io credo che
in 22 anni di alpinismo estremo fra le
tante cose che ho imparato ce ne sono
due in particolare che sento mia
e la prima è che secondo me proprio
l'uomo ha questa forza vitale forse è
una forza vitale con la quale riesce ad
affrontare le difficoltà anche quando
queste difficoltà sembrano insuperabili
dall'altro canto però bisogna stare
veramente attenti a scegliere quelle
persone che all'altro capo della corda
decideranno di rimanere in cordata con
noi e continuare a perseverare fino a
superare le difficoltà credo che questa
sia una lezione che avrei potuto
comprendere sin da bambino
se ci pensate quando noi nasciamo in
qualche modo voliamo nella vita
cerchiamo di decollare e c'è qualcuno
che sorregge i nostri voli che qualche
maniera ci fa sicurezza
ok solo che spesso man mano che
cresciamo che andiamo verso la vita non
ci rendiamo conto esattamente di questa
cosa a me ci è voluto un po per
impararla
però devo ammettere è che lo dico con un
po di ironia che se fosse stato un
pochettino più sveglio forse lo avrei
potuto capire molto prima di passare
quattro inverni intero della mia vita a
prender freddo al nanga parbat
grazie
[Applauso]